[Music]
you all saw Bill Clinton speak did you
see this that's the story last night
Bill Clinton gave a 49 49 minute speech
defending Obama's record that's what he
did yeah he praised Obama for saving the
economy passing health care and keeping
Hillary out of the country most the year
[Applause]
did you see this she's of East Timor
tonight I don't even know what the hell
that is after his speech everyone's
talking about this after his speech last
night President Obama surprised Clinton
by walking on stage and giving him a hug
surprised it yeah I'd have had it when
Bill Clinton saw a woman's husband
coming at him he threw his shoe and hid
in the closet
today's Scarlett Johansson
Kerry Washington and Eva Longoria all
spoke at the Democratic convention yep
this means Obama has all but clinched
the crucial 13 year old boy vote
there's a new Republican add that just
came out this elections really gonna get
nasty Georgia that's my prediction a new
Republican ad features a young woman
breaking up with a cardboard cutout of
President Obama
yeah the ad ends with her choosing a
cardboard cutout of Mitt Romney which
turns out to actually be Mitt Romney the
figures are in and Michelle Obama's
convention speech got higher ratings
than Ann Romney's yeah and tonight
tonight the Democrats are aiming even
higher when President Obama is
introduced by New DNC chair honey boo
boo now he's doing fine I want to stress
that he's doing fine but this morning
Tom Brokaw had to be taken to the
hospital after accidentally taking an
ambien yeah and tonight he was taken to
the hospital again after accidentally
listening to a speech by Joe Biden
clearly you've had some of the ambien as
well or the joke was no good today is
Chris Christie's Governor Chris
Christie's 50th birthday yeah that's
right yeah sadly he ate the cake before
the poor girl had a chance to jump out
of it so complain that the filling was
too crunchy
now we're hitting on both tell ya a boat
cylinders this is the finest two
cylinder engine and television sure
about this one a group of employees are
suing the Olive Garden for violating
federal labor laws yeah they're also
suing for violating the dictionary's
definition of Italian Tom Cruise y'all
heard about this Tom Cruise is being
accused of having the Church of
Scientology audition women to be his
wife I don't know what the problem is at
least someone in this economy is
actually still hiring someone's creating
jobs
[Applause]
in a new interview Vinny from Jersey
Shore says some of his co-stars are
destined for failure after the show ends
Benny said now if you'll excuse me I
have a pizza to deliver Kanye West Kanye
West has cancelled his VMA appearance
tonight because girlfriend Kim
Kardashian cannot attend yeah the news
is being reported as a win-win
[Applause]
now as I mentioned former President Bill
Clinton spoke last night at the DNC
crowd loved him they really did in fact
some Democrats are worried Clinton might
be overshadowing President Obama and I
got to tell you after watching Clinton
speech last night I can understand their
concern check this out mr. mayor
fellow Democrats we are here to nominate
a president I've got one in mind it's me
[Applause]
it was an awkward moment I gotta tell ya